take a good luck because this is the
face of a man who may have just spent
several hours analyzing his new favorite
chess game of all time
earlier this week LC zero faced off
against stock fish in the computer Chess
Championships and I knew when I saw it
that it would probably go down as the
best game I saw that week either by
human or one of our artificially
intelligent overlords but I didn't know
just how much I would enjoy it until I
began preparing for this video I'm gonna
jump ahead and play the first two moves
on the board to show you one of the main
reasons that this move tugs at the
heartstrings of this guy is because the
ston gambit is an approach I've been
playing against the Dutch for many years
believing in the principle idea that the
moment you can start prying open the
light squares against the weak and most
favorite target you could ever have in
the black army the better
but when Leela plays it the lovechild of
open-source engineering and alpha zero
if I'm allowed to say that I just did it
really grabs everyone's attention now as
a reminder any chess coach worth their
salt will teach their students that even
if you're not gonna play for efore in
the Staunton gambit if you're gonna play
systems with Knight f3 and g3 Allah
Vladimir Kramnik who loves positions
where you fiend kettle the bishop and
slowly engineer Eve or whether you're
gonna go for systems with c4 in d5 early
the bottom line is that you have to pry
open the light squares and create
opportunities to get at the fearless
leader of the black army in order to
properly expose the Dutch Black has
played a move that has willingly created
weak light squares and it's your job to
target them but efore is truly the most
unapologetic way excuse me to go for
this idea black obviously has to capture
it right defending f5 is a non-starter
especially if you want to play a move
like g6 as for those who like to keep
track of quick fools mates at home
something like this could be fun
but taking the pawn clearly the best
idea of course that's what stockfish
does and after the moves Knight to c3
and Knight f6 we get Bishop to g5 now if
you look up this position in the
database you may or may not find a game
by Daniel drench versus a grigory and
tell a game that I lost at the spice Cup
many many years ago in Lubbock Texas and
I actually faced what is the most common
approach for human players is black with
Knight to c6 and
for the move d5 Knight to e5 rather than
the more principled and traditional move
Queenie to wear White has a pretty
decent score I went for the idea Queen
to d4 which I don't think is that bad
I think that in the main game I had
against Grigory this fun Age 4 idea led
to a pretty decent potential middle game
end game and I probably could have
gotten a better position right here if I
hadn't played the move Knight G to e2 as
I did and instead played the move 1195
so this is me making making right with
the demons in my own pass you could find
that game in the database but a game
that will not be in the database is not
a game that I lost but a game that I won
against none other than grandmaster
gabriel Schwartzman in reno many years
ago one of the youngest grandmasters of
all time at some point he was actually
the record holder but Schwartzman in our
blitz battle blundered with the move d5
which is actually a common trick in the
Staunton gambit so I had to show it I
simply captured on f6 played between h5
regrain you regain not just the pawn but
very quickly you end up winning more
than a pawn and in fact I remembered
that the moves went where he sacrificed
f6 and tried to get an initiative on the
e-file but quickly after f3 was down to
pawns and ultimately went on to lose so
again these are a couple of my own games
with the Staunton gambit and shows you
the idea is very aggressive to open the
center try to look for tactics on the
white squares and this is what drives
the principles of the stone gambit if
you will but stockfish plays g6 not the
move Knight to c6 that untell played and
not the move d5 not the blunder this
Schwartzman played after g6 we get the
move Bishop to c4 one principled idea is
to play the move f3 and stockfish
actually played this move f3 against LC
0 when the colors reversed in season 13
over in our chess calm computer Chess
Championships you can check that game
out in the analysis that I've included
here a link over to Peter doctors news
report spend a lot of time analyzing the
game so you can check out the notes if
you're into that but we're gonna keep
going with what happened in the main
game Bishop to c4 a very good move again
d5 is not possible because white can
capture f6 first before then taking on
d5 with the bishop so instead after
Bishop to g7 Knight GT to black played
the move c6 now this is where things
first start to get spicy and we get to
really get get taken down the road
by Lila of just uncompromising
positional exposure of something your
opponent made wheat themselves the light
squares and everything that could
potentially come with that to the black
King c6 has a very obvious plan you want
to play d5 and if you achieve such goals
this is very very obviously very good a
huge pawn chain you're holding on to the
e for extra Pesce so white says no one
plays d5 but this is a principle thing
to do in any Dutch anyway you never want
black to be able to fully grip the light
squares that they're trying to do with
f5 and because they are also the key to
you getting exposure to the weak squares
it makes sense to always strive to keep
them open
so after d5 a stockfish plays the move
east six I did analyze that C takes d5
is no good after the move Bishop takes
d5 captures and Queen takes d5 we see
all kinds of problems where the King
can't castle East six is no bueno as
obviously your queen is hiding behind it
and natural moves might run into Knight
takes e4 where Knight to d6 check is
already a crushing threat followed by f7
being a checkmate square because the e7
pawn is pinned so that's just one idea
of just highlighting some of the dangers
that can happen to black if the light
scores start opening quickly so after
the movie six we get a very very fun and
original looking position with Knight
takes e4 and as I commented in my notes
whether computers are always improving
on top level humans when they play
original ideas or they go for these less
than popular opening lines even if it's
not always a technical improvement over
top level humans I think sometimes it is
and I think some top level V players
play very close attention to what's
going on in the computer chess
championship seeing how Lila and
stockfish are playing some crazy
positions but even if it's not always an
improvement a position like this is an
enjoyment to just watch you're looking
at a position that you will never see
it's a novel territory with so many
pieces hanging a million different ways
to capture a million different things
excuse me there with the bad highlight
but it's just a super fun and original
position to see in and gave me joy
analyzing it after Knight takes e4 black
castled just to point out a takes d5
right away would allow the move Knight
to d6 check preventing black from
castling and whites going to get a very
good attack and the move C takes d5
shows a really fun line after Bishop
takes d5 pawn takes d5 and a trade on f6
white actually is down a pea
but completely winning a position were
Knight to d6 check again followed by
entry with the queen is already very
hard to stop and even if you find a way
to do so things like Knight to c6 96
check in King e7 why can immediately
castlelong reinforce protection of the
night and here comes the other tower of
power joining the battle so just a very
very dangerous position not something
that the black is going to survive again
showing the lights core exposure so
black castles and after the move d6 we
see Lela was gonna ensure that when
black played c6 of humans ago he was
going to pay the price of bad Queen side
development it's nice to see of course
that it's it's just a principle thing
you would tell any of your students to
do right your opponent plays a move like
c6 which has an idea but comes in a
price of slowing down his own
development right taking away the
natural c6 square and you put that in
your pocket and you make sure that all
your moves are played with the goal of
how can I try to increase my advantage
and develop and how can I take advantage
of my opponent being behind if he moves
and that's really what's not stockfish
excuse me Lila does here with this move
d6 now after Queen a5 check we get
Bishop to D to the Queen moves over to
to e5 we see a trade on f6 and it's
right here right now that the whole
world stops and full disclosure the CEO
chest comm is a huge fanboy for computer
chess practically has a picture of Lila
not that not the creepy one that some
people use for their internet thumbnails
but a safe one above his office Eric I
emailed me and Robert has this game
right after it happened and said if you
guys seen this game what in the world
was F for you can't play a move like
that you're talking about a position
where you need to get your King castled
you have a pawn that's hanging on b2 and
f4 is a positional no no just a sped
fine called but it has the again the
just uncompromising willpower that I
know the way you take advantage of a
Dutch the king hiding behind the light
squares is you pry things open come hell
or high water so it's not just that Lee
the played the move f4 but after Queen
takes b2 rook b1 and castles this
particular position showed a plan that
started blowing people's minds in live
fashion as we said Eric sent me a game
it has had a
a lot of people least on my team talking
about ever since we get the move king h1
but every queen c5 you remove the check
and leave this says I didn't ever really
care about the check I got the King out
of safety so that in this position I
could shock you with the move f5 a
double exclaim in my book gives up a
free piece for no real clear forcing
line of checkmate
but again exposing that the light
squares are the problem in the Dutch
that you created stockfish when you
moved your F pawn a move one maybe it
was a mouse slit and I'm gonna take
advantage of the fact that I may be down
a piece in terms of how your mom sees
chess watching from afar up high she's
like oh it looks like my son has more
pieces off the board but a real chess
player sees what's on the board and says
what's on the board is not about the
pieces off the board and how they look
but the fact that many pieces are not
even playing yet sorry chess moms if I
imitated you there but that's just a
joke that I was told I was a kid and I
passed it on unwillingly apparently was
hidden deeply in my subconscious now
it's out thank you
but f5 is saying I'm gonna open up the
kingside the bishop is a small price to
pay for the fact that I have one two
three four and don't forget about
another rook who will quickly join the
fight the moment he hops on the lift and
takes the elevator over after a five
black took the bishop and fun stuff
starts really right here let's see so
rook to f4 exclam by the way I move like
rook to b4 I wanted to show that is not
as good because now when the Queen moves
and you take on g6 black can actually
trade off one piece one set of attackers
and on a move like this you can't just
keep bringing pieces over because you're
hanging too many pieces to keep track of
so stockfish may have may have hoped for
an idea like that but no brooke out for
wisdom move and after the between moves
we get F takes G 6h takes g6 and now
rook to g4 a lot of lines are gonna be
analyzed and shown for you in the
written analysis again the link you can
find below below and I'm gonna try to
show a lot of them here in the video
because I think it really illustrates
the attack so let's say if you take g6
black wanted to trade these are all
moves that if you turn on an engine I
let Komodo think for a long time wanted
to make sure I believed in everything
you can also use chess coms analysis and
see the eval bar take a very long time
before it starts to creep up and
understand the whites better but if rook
takes up four you can now take with temp
with the Queen and only then take on g6
us on h7 followed by the queen entering
and variations like this where the rook
comes over to g3 and the Queen night and
and all kinds of stuff are coming in is
just completely losing for black based
mainly on the fact that he's just down
three pieces an abusive Russian chess
coach would come along and just sweep
those off the board and say something
like you're not using them anyway why
you vote them and just throw them away
so that's one line that shows the danger
of of whites attack shh-shh g6 now we
get to keep the pieces on the board
again as I said this is why this
variation of rook F for first and not
rook to b4 as much as that could have
also been played with the tempo is
better after the move rook to f6 if you
really give the computers a long time to
think and in fact for fun kicks and
giggles I'm just gonna turn on this eval
bar here and let it show you how much it
likes black and if you turn them on
you'll find that Komodo stockfish they
all really like rook f2 for quite some
time that's the best move for black I
know because I went had a bowl of
oatmeal and let it think but the more
you give it time the more you see the
real depth of whites position the eval
bars not gonna come back but I'm gonna
keep playing moves that make you think
that black is still better the eval bar
and stock fish are gonna continue to
think that that black is better this
move is a fork by the way hitting both
the rook on g6 and the night on e2 but
after the move Queen to e4 we get to
move rook takes g7 absolutely brilliant
for Lita King takes g7 Knight to f4
double exclam blowing my mind the
threats are Queen to g4 along with
Bishop to c3 check there's almost no way
to deal with any of these mates besides
take more material right stock fish is
still gonna tell you that he likes black
after a few moves Bishop takes f4 Queen
takes f4 but here comes the shocker the
rook comes to b3 and there's no way to
deal with the two-man gang of the Queen
and rook for a mating net without giving
up your queen
several more moves in this line show you
that after checks attacking the Queen we
force the King back to g7 and win the
lady and now I finish the line out to
mate just to show you that this position
is not 5050 the computer just doesn't
understand it a few
moves the Queen enters and along with
their her trusty Jeep on we have a
completely winning position there we go
the eval bar kicks in and understands
that actually black is mated by force
and a variation like this shows the
trick with queen h7 and queen of seven
coming and you just can't stop it
so that's one line again I can't show
every line the main point of that was to
show you that there is still when it
comes to Leela playing stockfish anyway
a horizon effect that the best engines
can have the horizon effect is something
in chess where a human being knows my
intuition the Sun will rise the next day
so it starts making decisions even when
it's dark based on the fact that the Sun
is coming in giving a quick TLDR of the
the term and so Leela's ability to
understand the attack and the potential
exposes a horizon effect a limitation
that the computer just doesn't know that
black is just in huge trouble even after
the move rook f6 as was played it still
thinks that black is doing well but
after Knight c3 Knight to e4 Knight to
g3 Queen to h7 it still likes black
still likes black at a pretty decent
depth too depth of 20 and right now I'm
on here comes Bishop to g5 with frets of
rook h4 the main move in the game was
the move c5 which gave back the Queen
and at this point the computer started
to understand that that black was in
trouble but I wanted to analyze and
prove to you that even a move like
Bishop e5 which the computers like to
try to keep the Queen alive you may
indeed to be saving the lady and
variations like this but you're not
saving the game after Knight to e4 I
move like rook f5 is the best according
to the computer Bishop h6 the Queen
moves and then at the very very subtle
move that I found super cute it's just
Queen to e2 a simple move that not only
puts pressure on the bishop making a
move like g4 even harder to stop as the
Brooke gets overwhelmed trying to guard
the minister and the Square g5 for the
knight but also clears the square f1 I
showed a very very fun line to finish b5
G for the rook moves here we go we enter
the Brooke comes to f1 and as I said the
Queen lives for black at the end of a
variation like this unfortunately the
King does not so very very fun stuff I
like that line just highlighting White's
huge initiative and as I've shown some
of
the supercritical lines here and the
depth that Lela understood took a while
for stockfish to get it now that white
played rook h4 I'll go ahead and turn
the eval bar off and we will simply
complete complete the victory here that
L c0 did in fashion in style Queen takes
had to give herself up now black tries
to develop but it's too little too late
because here even with a bunch of pieces
for the Queen if you're doing the math
it's actually a rook a bishop and I
think at least a pawn or two we get the
move Knight to e5 Queen to a4 I love the
full board awareness because this move
this move is subtle because the whole
purpose of it the whole reason you play
it is to make sure that black still
can't get developed why does this move
do that well the only move to try to get
developed with me to get this Bishop out
in c8 the D pawn clearly is going
nowhere so the only option would be to
push the b-pawn well I put the Queen on
a4 precisely so that I could meet b6
with rook takes b6 and that's exactly
what happened in the game you can't take
it because Queen takes a e8 would have
been lights out so Knight to c4 the rook
comes back and I've still been
preventing by the way the development of
the bishop so by taking these six you
are officially for the first time
threatening to develop that Bishop to
the b7 square because the knight defends
it but after Queen to g4 Bishop to b7
you've you've traded one for another you
got developed but your knight had to
leave the e5 square and therefore the
protection of the g6 pawn behind white
continues to play a good natural moves
freeing the back ring nothing likely the
telling us humans we've been right all
along play prophylactic chests just free
your King off the back rank when you
don't know what else to do here comes a
rook to the e7 square which would have
been a trade eliminating a defender of
the g7 Bishop right that was the threat
of a rook e1 which is why black played
this move Bishop to e4 the white trades
and eliminates and heads to an endgame
where the Queen is much more powerful
than the two Brooks let me explain why
I'm not trying to undo or go through too
quickly over the fact that this is still
very good technique leaders about to
show but from even a human perspective
you're looking at the most powerful
piece on the board with weaknesses on
all sides of the board right whenever
you have pawned weaknesses and an open
King these are the types of positions
where the Queen flexes her muscles in in
dominant fashion because she can do
things
peices who have to coordinate together
to have a safai ting chance just can't
do when the board is split the center is
open there are weaknesses on all sides
and that's that's a quick sort of
summary of why white is able to kind of
dominate the next several moves of this
position a balance of using your your
kingside advantages and knowing this
king is weak combined with keeping your
eye on weaknesses on the queenside are
exactly how lila takes advantage of this
type of position moving the Queen again
all kinds of threats coming here a seven
hanging things like Bishop to d4 coming
so black tries to give a check for good
measure rook to d6 Queen c5 we're moving
pieces it doesn't matter at this point
white is going to simplify and again
open King's and patent multiple paths
pawns are where the Queen will always do
dirty things to do a bunch of little
pieces trying to coordinate against her
majesty and so we see a very very nice
kind of game here again checking on e2
heading to a lost King upon ending no
bueno you've got too much to deal with
his black so just a matter of time with
Leo flexing targets on both sides past
pawns on both sides and that's exactly
what she does here this nice little game
of tickle by the way always prevented
black from being able to capture this D
pawn now she guards e5 in more dominant
fashion checks the king and just a move
she gets back to pushing her pawns here
we go
pawns and advancements happening on both
sides of the board the kind of thing
that two rooks have nightmares about a7
by the way you could not capture it
because Queen to e7 would simply win the
rook right there okay so not possible
rook a8
but the commitment you've made to this
side of the board has left something
else open and that's when the other
pawns get advancing so again very very
just solid technique but because she
never even allows the rooks and came to
coordinate not even totally necessary
but will give her the benefit of the
doubt that being leavea playing the kind
of moves we can all aspire to be and
then this nice little finishing
technique here we won't call me a troll
it's an unnecessary capture to play
Queen takes rook but we've we've talked
about this forever people have you know
they've been suspicious they don't
understand is there more than just open
source engineering or they really just
letting the neural-net do her thing if
so how does she become a natural troll
when she doesn't need to be right it's
it's it's crazy because any of these
other moves are also completely winning
but she sees that she can give back the
Queen and flex the two pawns versus the
rook just to have a little more fun I
always I always tried to teach her not
to play with her food but she wouldn't
listen and and here we go
Lila just dominating Queen versus rook
and eventually as we play through the
last moves well just see how she takes
care of business in fact here again this
is this is again how is this not a troll
how is this not a troll I don't
understand how these engineers get away
with saying that they're not teaching
her something I don't know why she does
it
people have explained and I'm sure
people be listening in the comments what
it is about the algorithm and the neural
net that has her want the game to
continue longer than it needs to but she
just gives back the pawn to head to a
queen versus rook the kind of position
that human beings have nightmares over
because these aren't supposed to be that
easy to win but for Lila it's apparently
just a walk in the park to go advance
with the king and eventually get the
Philidor position by the way good
technique the king should always lead
the way and get as close as possible
while the Queen should flex in central
squares on diagonals and preventing the
rook from ever separating because that's
when the checks open up and you
eventually get squares like this where
you're checking a king and attacking the
rook on c1 these kind of things are why
you want a queen centralized and the
king getting as close as possible in a
king and queen versus king and rook
endgame so you get a unintentional quick
lesson there that Lila gave us because
she's such a troll eventually the rook
has been separated and she's gonna by
the way notice that great technique
again the Queen guarded this Square
which allowed the king to step forward
without having to worry about a check
from the rook
so she's just getting closer and closer
to getting that force check where you
attack both King and rook and the rest
as they say is just a matter of
technique i'm gonna click forward to get
to our final moment which is checkmate
on the square called b2 so again this is
this has been one of the most enjoyable
experiences that I never asked for
during our koban 19 crisis hope everyone
is safe healthy and staying as sane as
possible if you happen to hear any
screaming that I did during the video
those are my boys playing table
downstairs in the garage they know a lot
more about talking trash and yelling
than they do about actually executing on
a proper over-the-top forehand but
regardless of that forgive forgive it I
hope you're doing well and as I said the
gift of focusing on some great chess
that's been going on without any other
events to distract and watching the
computer chess championships has been a
joy
shoutout to leaveth who continues to do
awesome things thanks for watching
please give a like please give a share a
subscribe if you're into it let people
know how much you enjoy these analysis
videos and I shall see you around on
chess comm